[Musique]
ils étaient 7 ce lundi 4 avril à la
villa du département a signé les
conventions partenariales pour le
développement du logement social à la
réunion et l'accompagnement des
réunionnais dans le cadre du projet eco
d'heure
cette convention elle est d'abord le
symbole de l'unité défense autour du
logement avec le département
l'union
social habitat outre mer
là ces hommes
maurice gironcel été à mes côtés
françois caillé était là les
associations d'usagers
et c'est l'expression comme je le dit
d'une solidarité à l'échelle du
territoire de la réunion nous voulons
dire que lorsque nous sommes unis nous
avons plus de chances de réussir et
c'est ça le sens de ce matin les
différents acteurs ont évoqué la
nécessité d'élaborer un projet
réunionnais ce projet réunion à la
réunion ça effectivement il faut le
faire avec ce qu'on appelle et bien
la conférence territoriale et large
qu'on mette autour de la table tous ceux
et celles qui veulent travailler pour
notre pays pour le développement notre
pays les acteurs économiques les
syndicats les associations mais aussi
bien sur les politiques les élus et
consorts un projet enfin réunionnais et
que quel que soit le président en
afrique et en france qu'on lui dise
voilà notre projet régnait on s'est
entendus entre nous nous vous demandons
une loi programme sur 10 5 10 15 15 ans
pour faire face aux nombreux défis que
nous avons à relever tout le temps c'est
paris qui décide pour nous - plusieurs
reprises qui parle peu en parlent au nom
et or cette organisation permet aux
outremers de venir voter directement à
eux et à nous et c'est eux qui vont être
avec nos élus et s'est porté au niveau
national et au niveau des ministères
dits formica logement et aux différents
assemblée sénat et député à l'assemblée
nationale
ça nous apparaît eu une bonne avancée
pour que enfin il n'y a pas cinquante et
un locuteur on nous consulte avant votre
mère et puis après pour la convention
économes a pour objectif de faire
diminuer la charge locative des
locataires à travers les économies
d'énergie on donne un exemple tout bête
lorsqu'on change en vain dans un
immeuble on chante toutes les langues
les vieilles lampes qui consomment
beaucoup des led ou diminuent diminuer
la consommation et les fustes et par 5
par dix c'est juste impressionnant voilà
un exemple voilà le genre de choses
qu'on va faire comment permettre au
bailleur de faire ce type de travaux de
façon suspecte alala à l'arrivée les
charges locatives des locataires baisse
ces mission
[Musique]